we are back the frenemies
are we friends or enemies today we're
friends that's nice i think we're
friends for sure
you know we've been through a lot on
this show and only what eight episodes
this is our ninth episode it everyone
thought i think they were confused that
a lot of people thought was the finale
last episode well we were just ending
the show did you see those comments
like oh what a good way to end the
series
we saw those comments yeah maybe we
should have ended it
oh this is eight we've come we've
traveled i've actually covered a lot of
ground i have to say in eight
only eight sessions these are sessions
by the way therapy
i really really like dr dre i met him a
few times i don't know if he remembered
me i feel like he like he did he
mentioned
it yeah i was setting it up he said that
he met you on adam
carolla's show right yeah but i've been
like a few times and every time i meet
him it's like the first time he's like i
don't really know anything about you i'm
like every time i talk to you i tell you
the same thing
i've always told them like in on the
adam curler show we talked about like me
being trans and i'm like oh that's fine
i mean i guess he
talks to a lot of people i like him
though i really do like him it was good
yeah
i thought he was great my parents were
supportive of it they don't watch
anything but they found out and they
were like oh like
you know usually i could scare what my
parents think when i talk about
childhood but they were
oh your your parents don't watch your no
well you mostly do like
nasty stuff well my mom watches
everything but my dad doesn't but in
case he found out about it
does your mom watch your only fans
content my mom wasn't an only fan she
was in the one with my sister she was
like the referee of the jello
would your mom ever show her titties
yeah she has she has on youtube
yeah but it was more like when she had
breast cancer and she was showing like
her
nipples that's more like brave
but she's sexy oh well she would do it
sexy too you should do it down for sure
would you do it only would you like to
do would you slap titty with your mom
titty with a hand or titta tit to ted i
don't see anything wrong with it i just
would think
people would like you know people are so
sensitive about things it's like
i don't know anyone in the market for
some
some i think people go crazy yeah and
today today only for the election day
it's free so if you join today
onlytrash.com is free for the next 30
days so if you want to see tip for tips
it's free
it'll come this month yeah for the next
thing in honor of the election
yeah because we're in the land of the
free oh my god
how's that okay cool cool good promotion
so that's your election vote free for a
whole month
yeah free for a whole month what's the
point of that because you know what once
you're in there
you're so enticed to stay i just got to
get people in because they don't really
realize all the goods
mine is really good not to like whatever
my only hands is like really good
compared to everyone else i subscribe to
so many people
and mine without a doubt gives you the
most like for five dollars a month but
now it's free and people just stay
as i understand that tris is just
squirting all over her house
yeah all over the place right moses
moses said yes it's crazy it's it's
insane every time i do it i'm like wow
that's kind of cool because i just
learned how to properly do it all right
we're not here to plug your only fans
the whole episode thank you
um and congratulations on your
nomination
for the h3 podcast it's on first
streaming i was very excited for oh i
was like what
they they put me there every year do you
guys ever win no
who wins i don't know you're up against
impulsive
oh tough competition confused
the usual suspect um there was one that
was so bad who was it remember i was
like
who the oh i'm a chamberlain hers isn't
wait why isn't joe rogan's
podcast nominated then oh you won't show
up like i think they think you guys
might show up no i never show up i
i don't like the streamies why i just
i you know what nothing personal i think
it's cool that there's a that there's
that for
what we do i think award shows are dumb
though it's [ __ ] they have like a
food category and
of like the best like mukbangers and i'm
never nominated i'm like the og the best
all might get like millions of views
like
yeah but it's all politics like they
literally don't it's
literally nothing to do with who's
actually the best
and all and then their biggest
categories
are just about how it's fan vote so it's
all about these
really vain creators doing everything
they can to beg their fans to vote for
them well because tana won creator of
the year of sharon was like what the
[ __ ] is because she's literally like
i'll suck your tits if you vote like she
did that with biting
yeah did you see that oh yeah the fbi
was like uh uh
i think that's illegal he got
investigated by the fbi yeah it's
because she was saying like hey like if
you guys vote for biden and prove it to
me like i'll just give you a free nude
yeah fbi is like she's
well i think she was trying to do there
was this one girl who was like
dan you know what i'm talking about
where she sent nudes to everyone who
voted for something but it wasn't
illegal like what tana was
doing or it was for registering i think
it was for the wildfires people who
donated
thank you yeah she was like hey donate
to the wildfires and i'll send you nudes
and tana's like
great idea i'll make i'll do a federal
crime
yeah she's not the brightest bulb um i i
saw she did something people were
calling out for photoshopping over the
weekend
and you know what can i just say as much
as i was like against your video
i mean she really does overdo it because
i did see the side-by-side from this
weekend
because she had to come up with a
statement being like hey i always do
talk about this and she does she talks
about pho
but it was like that okay the pictures
you showed were actual ones if you went
to my fabio music video plug and saw i'm
like wearing that makeup and it looks
like me in the video but like
when it's unrecognizable she's a
different person okay that's what i was
saying
it's like you look like and what i said
was
twinkie which is rude and i would never
say that but i do but like again a
reference to her
swimsuit yeah i want to see it okay but
then when you look at her she's like a
different person
who's that italian model perfect
figure she takes care of herself
well she does have she has a good body
but she but even like her face she just
changed her whole face shape and i'm
like
again like not wondering what's the
point of being a model yeah well i don't
think she's a model i could be a model
just be like turn me into like handsome
squidworth be like
and then i'm like six packs and my face
is all chiseled yeah
you know it could be a model yeah with
enough photoshop
oh here it is here it is but why not
just use a body double
but this isn't even that way horn let me
see okay so this is like
you can tell how airbrushed her face is
but like look at her face
she looks like that is like not even her
like i was i was so
i was so shocked because and she is
pretty like i think she's pretty okay oh
my gosh oh my gosh
she's obviously very insecure but it's
like a different profile like different
everything
i guess the blonde hair but uh like yeah
i don't know i i think just don't overdo
it but
she got like a team she sends all of her
photos to yeah i think she does it
herself i don't know if she doesn't
you don't think no [ __ ] way she does
well anyway it's i
got a team she's like all right guys
here's my photos for the day make me
pretty
it does get a little a little crazy
thank you
that was my whole point but guys do it
too and i think you should call out guys
you don't call out your guy friends like
i
you know like you don't call the guys
that do it i'd love to who does it
philip defranco
we saw you on lin's defranco's tick tock
phil defranco
doesn't photoshop himself he does
hold on you gotta bring receipts you
said angles
angles wait angles is not photoshopped
haven't gone misleading hold on having a
good angle
is not photoshopped here we go being
misogynistic and not
going oh look well you don't i wouldn't
i've heard a shot why would i ever call
a girl for
a good angle i'm gonna no but that's
mine i don't photoshop i never have
photoshop my phone
he can tell i don't know how to use
facetune i've never faced in a picture
in my life okay
okay this one that is not the same
person
that is not the same person on his show
and so it's like how come you don't call
that person out
just because he's not the same wait that
looks like a guy in a casket if you ask
me
like that looks like a corpse and you
don't pull them out
okay back up because you're such a good
bias oh my god
hold on back it up you have idubbbz
meanwhile he's the biggest hypocrite of
anybody and it's like with that whole
only fans [ __ ] and stuff like that
like okay
you know about your friends hold on [ __ ]
marry kill
idubbbz jack's films or philip defranco
go
wait hold on exactly they're all your
friends they won't say anything bad hold
on you just
there's a lot to address there okay
first of all
regarding that philip defranco footage
you showed me
i feel like for some reason you just
want to call him fat
absolutely not but if you're going to
call me out for being fat and skinny
then call him out for being fat and
wait hold on philip defranco is sitting
there looking face on in the camera
doing the news he's not walking around
in a bikini trying to be hot
i disagree and he's not manipulating the
footage at all
he will and it i mean it looks like he
gained a few pounds
you're being very nice as opposed to
calling tana a [ __ ] twinkie and now
you're like
but it's different he looks like a
twinkie no but he's not
trying to out there trying to look like
a sexy fit
model like tana is out there being like
ooh
look at me i'm perfect body and i'm a
model i'm a
swimsuit model and then she's turning
around and [ __ ] eating a
[ __ ] you know uh egg mcmuffin meal
i think she's very skinny tana's very
skinny i don't think she eats egg
mcmuffin meals i think that's not the
issue i think your issue is just like
you hate women you're misogynistic
dude that's why you like wait hang
around with those people
you're uh blue you're okay philip
defranco
i admit looks heavier than you would
expect and you look skinnier than you
would expect in person most people look
skinnier than you would expect
okay thank you however i don't think
what philip i don't think that's the
same you can look skinnier or fatter in
person be honest
you can be honest i think you look the
same as you do on camera you do
yeah i think i do look fatter in person
for sure like when i see other people
really no you don't look fatter in
person thanks i'm trying to lose some
weight today because i literally feel
like i'm about to have a heart attack
that's why i'm a little on edge today
i felt my chest and i'm like i'm going
to eat a salad after this you can wait
you said too much
we didn't say to go vote today this is
my first lesson okay
that's dude that's great thank you
i'm so happy you voted i did it for the
tick tock where it was like oh
man you ruined it no because there's a
tick tock where it's like
young me and then me now and so i was
like me four years ago like looking at
me voting now and i was like wow
would you vote if there wasn't a tick
tock trend be 100
[ __ ] honest
no yeah i don't think so i don't think
so
but they hey whatever works to get
people out to the polls uh yeah well you
really changed
from four years ago that that's the tick
tock trend
four years ago girl goes wow you know
what i mean that's like a cool tread
and michael keaton we watched him thank
you michael king i started we watched
michael keaton before this and i'm
crying right now because
i was crying watching that because i was
like i never will get to be friends with
michael keaton i just
i love him so much he wouldn't photoshop
his body he wouldn't do angles
he shows everything about him oh well
beetlejuice is not an accurate
representation how much makeup was he
wearing
okay wait i want to talk about voting
pittsburgh shout out
wait before we talk about voting first
you said you said philip defranco
is fat and then what else did you say
that i needed to address
um the items is a hypocrite no i think
like because the we should we should
[ __ ] marry kell idubbbz jax films or
philip defranco you have to kill like
avoid one we won't get into the james
charles scandal i don't like i refuse to
play this game
you have to avoid somebody not kill them
oh avoid
yeah we're not stupid i'm not playing
this game why do i need to play this
game i don't want to piss anybody off i
like those people
you know what i mean it's like i i
choose not to play
trish wants to do if i have an activity
to bring up you're like no okay fine
i'll do it i'll do it
jack philip defranco and idubbbz
so it's [ __ ] mary a void
yeah or [ __ ] mary cass put them on a
deserted island
yeah we don't kill people that's
impolite
james charles james charles kills people
he said he'd kill shane dawson which i
think is a little aggressive
saying knowing that he doesn't like that
person that'd be like me saying i want
to kill philip defranco because everyone
knows i don't like him so that's what
i'll talk about
because i have thoughts on that too do
we want to talk about i don't know no
but yes we do
not to keep us my name out of his mind
well you already failed his people are
coming for you now
nobody really likes james anymore okay i
would um
i just took too much duncan i'm just on
a little crack right now i feel it i
would cast away philip defranco
i would hell yeah and i would probably
tell me why i would probably marry jack
because he's very sensitive and caring
and i feel like he really is attentive
to your needs and i think he would be a
good husband
he was rude to me on the shane dawson
set five years there's no chance that he
was he's
so nice he's not i guarantee you he
wasn't rude too but
he wasn't nice to me at this actually at
the shorty awards when david and jason
won
the awards yeah jack was there by
himself because he knew he was going to
win by the way
shorty awards tell you and i think
stream you tell you too if you're going
to win but jack knew he was going to win
and he was at the table he was like
stevo talks to all the guys but refuses
to look me and i
even like talk to him i'm like yeah we
met just looked the other way like
literally looked like i wasn't even
talking and he was sitting right at my
table
one feet away from me he's kind of rude
okay and then he's just shy and then
items i would [ __ ] because
um he's got crazy energy and you know
he's a good [ __ ] items his girlfriend's
only fans of the ripoff she
acts like it's so like raunchy and nude
and stuff and then i like what i'm like
oh it's like instagram photos which is
fine but she's like
someone she says up front that it's a
non-nude she says they're sexy photos
and they are definitely not sexy it's
just her like standing there they're not
like sexy poses her ass isn't like
jutting out for like a dick in it or
anything like that
oh that was sweet i was very
disappointed and then she makes you
unlock the photos so i'm like paying and
like there's nothing and she kind of
does tea like
titties and it's just like her like
holding them i'm like well say you're
holding titties don't stay there too
you want her to show the tit the goods
just don't say you are gonna show them
yeah if she's gonna compete with you
squirting on like
squirting under the sink and stuff yeah
we just did a full
i got like
jesus christ do we get demonetized well
there's yeah there's certain things that
we can't talk about
okay regarding voting this episode
i've been thinking about this a lot so i
wrote up a few things and yes i know
you're only supposed to talk about
politics if you have a political science
uh
doctorate's degree okay okay oh yes a tr
a triple doctor it's no
but you know how people online go oh
you're why don't you stick to comedy or
whatever
people say when they don't agree with
your political opinions
so oh so yes i know i'm not a doctor
it's in political science but i have
some
this episode comes out tuesday morning
sorry excuse me election day election
day
and here's why i want here i'm gonna
make my case
for why you should go out and vote if
you haven't voted
and any of these points are persuasive
to you please pause this video we will
not go anywhere
we will be here you pause it you can
come back you can play it
here's things that i care about that
that the joe biden democratic ticket
supports oh okay you're endorsing a
candidate yeah i think we should say
like vote for who you want i don't think
you like endorse someone well why don't
you hear me out for okay okay
do you support the women's right to
choose what happens to her body
no matter how extreme the circumstances
are are you asking me or that
i'm just a general question oh yeah of
course of course right
yeah because one the republican party in
the republican ticket
wants to make abortion illegal even in
the most extreme
circumstances like life-threatening or
forced
upon them even by a family member
okay that's pretty that that to me is is
okay whatever some people believe yeah
some people believe every child is a
gift from god some people believe that i
don't believe that i'm just saying some
people do believe that
yeah and even as i said
do you believe that climate change is
the most urgent
is is an urgent uh uh time bomb that we
need to
face immediately and and boldly i have
no idea what that is
that's okay climate change climate
change oh boy you don't know what you
don't know climate changes
man-made climate change carbon carbon
carbon in the air carbon what monoxide
or dioxide
both you know that the earth is is
warming
um i don't i don't miss
the memo on climate change is it gonna
happen in my lifetime because i don't
have kids holy [ __ ]
are you sure you want everyone to vote
because sometimes when i went i was like
i'm kind of dumb at some of these things
maybe i shouldn't be voting
like when i had to fill out the other
yeah maybe you shouldn't i was like oh
and i didn't know because you don't have
to you don't you can oh i didn't know
that you can just you're just like oh
[ __ ] like a
like a scan like a a b test you don't
know that i failed an a b test one time
for a reality show i just randomly did
it like i did
well no i didn't randomly vote but i did
like i randomly filled out an a b
test for this show we did with scott
disick and i failed cause i said i saw
like shapes or shifts or like something
like that and they they
told me i like can't be on the show
because i was like mentally insane
but it was randomly filled out i didn't
anyways oh my god okay i don't know
climate change okay so climate change
how do you go through life and not know
about climate change you know the earth
why don't you tell me the ice is melting
the sea is rising but what does that
even have to do like okay the ice melts
then what happens
then like florida goes underwater
literally because it raises the sea
level
it's florida okay fair enough
it's not like yeah a lot of people think
well you know
but like okay good fair enough um can i
just say i do like biden
did you notice it's hot like in the
summer like really hot
i mean we're in california and israel
it's not there not in israel no i'm
saying it's hot in israel all the time
you know we're not in israel right
i want to do a podcast in israel though
i was going to bring this up to you
because i might move here for a couple
months so i was like
we should go well once the pandemic's
done me and ila would love to go visit
really we usually go there every year
but we haven't been in a while can we
come with you
that'd be fun a couple you go first
class or coach sorry not to get
distracted well we haven't we
you're first class i know you the last
time we went was coach this time would
be first class we got the baby
we've had uh we've had we're doing
better
the last time we went was like two or
three years ago so we're rich now you
are bougie as [ __ ]
you're the bougiest i think you're the
richest person i know off youtube what
about jeffrey
uh i think you might make more than no
[ __ ] i think so
i swear no way jeffrey lives in like a
15 million dollar house
you could live you have multiple houses
that are over 15 million dollars
am i exposing something like that people
wrote articles about it okay
well you have multiple properties that
are worth a lot of money and i'm always
like okay
yeah i'm pretty well i think you may i
think teddy fresh makes more than
jeffree star cosmetics
there's no [ __ ] way just because his
overhead is probably more true with all
like
overhead what does she pay for it's like
some powder and [ __ ]
i mean on those chain series they said
like you know the private jets and stuff
come out of the costs and stuff you
don't pay well
that's his own [ __ ] fault i don't
know i know but that's out of the
business expense i think you guys are a
little more
like logical i don't know i don't know
don't come for me i'm pretty sure
jeffrey start to do a net worth jeffree
star i know this these things are stupid
but
dude jeffree star's got to be worth like
50 mil plus i think you're worth more
i'm gonna wait for my bets on that you
think what does it say
it says he's worth 200 million which
yeah i don't think you're i don't think
it's not accurate mine is you know what
can i can i break something to you
i don't think i think that that might be
closer than what you think
he's super rich makeup is one of the
most profitable industries
because it costs like nothing to make
because like you sell it for like 50 60
70 bucks and it costs like two bucks to
make
right i don't know i don't know the
behind the scenes of it all
i'm just that's i'm guessing you're
probably me more
um back to buying well thank well thank
you for saying that
you're very bougie thank you so i like
being friends with you i love bougie
people oh really i feel like it rubs off
on me and like the more like
why you're bougie too you told me what
you make i've [ __ ] yeah i spend it
i'm like buying earrings inside like i
wear all my money i'm like [ __ ]
you write off private jets through your
i don't do private sessions
i'm not a private jet person show off
your new rolex well i don't know if i
should
but there's that's what i'm saying this
is why i'm like
because i just 85 000 presidential rolex
it's beautiful
but i told trisha it is gorgeous by the
way i think it's really beautiful but i
would be afraid to take it out of my
jewelry box
shout out to ice box they'd hook up all
the rappers and they hooked me up
but they actually hooked me up a little
bit but you know trisha told me she's
like [ __ ] it i'm pretty i'm going to
mcdonald's with this thing on
because dave belvin he has all his
diamonds at mcdonald's okay wait let me
do my vote [ __ ]
okay this is pro biden right apparently
if you
just listen to the points climate change
which apparently
some people don't know what that is
you said the ice melts and then florida
like falls off it's
maybe it's just too hard you should
probably educate people because i'm sure
a lot of people don't know that one for
real
i don't know dude you're the only person
in the [ __ ] world that doesn't know
about climbing
i'm the only person i can guarantee most
how many i mean i i don't want to
include you to cause friction but i just
trying to get a read of the room
do you think that a lot of people don't
know what climate change
school now so is knows they didn't teach
it to us i swear
hand to god dan do you think that
there's more than
her listening right now that knows what
climbing i'm not trying to be rude i'm
just trying to get a feel for the room
i think i think the vast majority okay
you're you said a read of the room we're
like literally a room of nerds right now
like i'm just saying like all right
okay hold up maybe ask an instagram
model they're not gonna know climate
change you know what i mean
they will you think tana mojo knows
climate change i guarantee you she does
not i
guarantee you she does not okay but
anyway this isn't about climate change
because it's a whole
thing if you don't included it in your
speech you're not even educating people
so you're a [ __ ]
everybody knows what climate change is
okay whatever next
next are you are you sick of paying more
in taxes than billionaires
this one i'm gonna have to disagree on
because i know they say if biden goes in
then including you
yeah taxes are going up i'm fine with
that i'm not fine with it because i
don't like what it goes towards to like
places like planned parenthood and stuff
like
like i'm all for do what you want with
your body you don't like planned
parenthood i just don't want my taxes to
go there
like dude the federal good okay
wait wait so but like i'm talking about
so the taxes through biden's plan is
only for people who make
over four hundred thousand a year i
heard that wasn't completely true
it is true okay well that's like again
you're like it's like fact check it dan
check it out no no no no no no no let's
fact check it
for trump i'm just saying like no but
this is good let's fact check it
does joe biden's tax plan increase taxes
on anyone making over four hundred
thousand dollars a year
you already said it i'm bougie as [ __ ] i
don't i'm i'm happy to pay more taxes if
it means people can
have health insurance and [ __ ]
colleagues the poor should think about
health insurance so under obama i could
not get health insurance because of
pre-existing condition
so they don't give it to everybody a
thousand percent could not i didn't get
health insurance under obama or
obamacare because i had a pre-existing
condition and they would not insure me
it was
[ __ ] it was actually [ __ ] which
i feel like it's gonna happen again
it's a thousand percent hand to god it's
like it happened to me and it was awful
during those that time
well you have it now yeah i'm gonna have
you have it for the obamacare
no no like oh my my previous condition i
solved the condition yeah
but you have health insurance yeah but
it's not through obamacare you have just
one private yeah
it's hella expensive okay so four
non-partisan tax groups have agreed that
biden's plan
will not directly increase taxes for
anyone
making under four hundred thousand
dollars a year and what's the website
newsweek well it's newsweek reporting on
it but it's
for no i've looked into this this is
like other things where people just
don't say the full thing like the
criminal after 1994 and the deportation
laws and all that like that like it's
very one-sided like
i'm not saying i'm for trump definitely
not but i'm saying
on this on this issue of taxing
you know if the taxes don't go up for
people making four hundred thousand
dollars
is is indisputably correct because trump
is on the campaign trail saying
he's raising everyone's taxes that's not
true and i'm happy to pay more
taxes if it means people can have health
insurance i would be too if that was
true but people don't get health
insurance and i was one of those people
under the obama fair that did not get
the health insurance so
it's kind of [ __ ] i'm not going to
lie now what also i'm referring to is
people like donald trump who pay 750
in taxes meanwhile his secretary pays
more money in taxes than he does
i think that's [ __ ] up and that's why
i am
supporting job another reason why i'm
supporting joe biden oh wow oh my god
you're like casey and i said over here
like i'm voting for
you're just saying it these are all
these are all things i care about i
respect
the health do you believe that health
insurance is a right
and not a privilege it should be i agree
do you think that people with
pre-existing conditions should be able
to get
insurance no and i'm 1000
and it was a time when i needed it like
i actually needed insurance and couldn't
afford it like it was actually really
really a bad time in my life it was
really dark so i'm really adamant about
this that like
you say that but they don't promise it
so don't think you're gonna be getting
health insurance for pre-existing
conditions because you're probably not
okay do you well that's what obamacare
is and the republicans are working to
dismantle it
and to make and they're what they're
working towards is that people
with pre-existing conditions can be
denied uh health insurance coverage
so we both agree on that and that's what
joe biden's expanding
okay do you want supreme court justices
that are literal cast members from
gileads
from the handmaidens tale have you seen
that no i have no idea they're like
they're religious extremists that are
literally out of comic book villainy
that want to overturn
rover suede and make they want to over
make abortion illegal and they want to
make
gay marriage illegal okay again yeah and
that's not cool well that's [ __ ] up
and that's why i'm voting
another reason why i'm voting for joe
biden
you know why i vote for joe biden
because he's because of uh michael
keaton
no he quoted hamilton did you see that
done
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created
he said that in his speech oh my god
you know what that's from hamilton no
but you know what it's from
you know that i mean it comes from
before hamilton right well everything
comes before hamilton because he got
all from history books like it's all
historically accurate
so are you telling me it's like a like
probably a quote from somebody
yeah it's yeah it's an important quote
i was i respected it i was like okay
hamilton
it's actually from uh the it's from the
uh
the constitution or the bill of rights
what you don't even know oh the
[ __ ] you did god you don't even know
don't even be like wow you don't know oh
it's from the well i
i didn't think that hamilton wrote it i
didn't think hamilton
wrote it but i knew it was from hamilton
which i thought was cool because he's
trying to bring the younger generation
be like here is it okay
cut the part out where i got it wrong
dan
i'll go do an exposed video on you if
that's all
bill of right or the declaration of
independence i knew that it wasn't
written by
manuel [ __ ] whatever his name is
we hold these truths yeah so do you
believe that gay and trans rights are
human rights hell yeah this is why i
vote
right here well then that's why i
support joe biden
yeah i'm all for that because i think
that
going back in time and overturning
the right for gay people to get married
is barbaric and [ __ ] medieval
and evil everything i do is for gay
people i kind of
care less about straight people i just
do everything i mean
a large part of the republican party and
conservative movements thinks that tran
trans people are are like
i don't want to put words in their mouth
but there's a lot of hate for trans
people and i think that
trans people those people should burn in
hell that if they think trans people
aren't like people deserving of like
rights and like
protection and places to work like
that's some [ __ ]
like those are the people that go to
[ __ ] hell with hitler
we can all agree go went to hell that's
they're all playing
[ __ ] solid or what do they do in hell
whatever they're doing they're doing it
burn they burn bird baby eternity
you know [ __ ] hitler i have a so mad
about that still i have a
are you still mad at him like i didn't
know that you
i think that's why i've always loved
like jews because i always had like
empathy and i wanted just to give them
love and
well i feel really i feel for trans
people it's
so difficult it's such a hard thing to
grapple with
as on a personal level and then society
is so cruel about it
and still kind of coming to terms with
it like it's it's very much where
homosexuality was
back in like you know the 60s and 70s
where it's like
it's it's people outcast you and
and don't respect your stroke yeah we're
now but anyway if you believe that gay
and trans
rights are human rights then that's why
i support joe biden okay
do you want to a president that believes
in science
um i'm more favorite you could you could
give or take
i love my jesus and he's the ruler of
everything he controls everything it's
all up to him
are you serious yeah okay with jesus
like you don't need to worry he's got it
mapped out like
so does that mean that donald trump
should or shouldn't tell people to wear
masks or
or his will not mine
what i prefer my president to believe in
science that means
that a president that listens to a
scientist and follows their advice and
that's why i'm voting
for joe biden you should watch god's not
dead starring kevin sorbo
and make some really good pieces against
scientists
who try and deny god and his existence
it's pretty good kevin sorbo yeah yeah
and dean kane
well i don't know if i want to put dean
cute i don't think scientists tried to
deny god i think atheism is more
atheism means i have no reason
no evidence to believe in god so it's
not that i'm saying god doesn't exist
it's just saying i have no reason to
even consider this a possibility i don't
think so i think that's something else i
think atheist
atheists like literally deny god like
god does not exist like
he's kind of describing that yeah
agnostic atheism sorry yeah
atheist yes some atheists are douches
hardcore yeah
some of them are douchebags i agree but
i think most people would say
i just we don't know there's no way to
know and so that therefore i don't
you know okay um
do you want a president that encourages
people to wear masks
and stop the spread of covet instead of
enabling people and turning mass into a
partisan
issue for example laura ingraham was at
trump's
rally and he called she was wearing a
mask he goes
oh look it's laura ingram how
politically correct she's wearing a mask
wow i didn't expect that okay i mean
that's just kind of like a cute little
like sassy comment i feel you to help
people kind of like bully people
that's like a cute little bully is that
really something you want to bully
people about no
i mean it's a mask like people wear it
or they don't i think you should wear it
but like are you gonna really be like
you don't think the president making
jokes like that and always wearing not
wearing his masks and
i think there's bigger issues than being
like wow look at that loser not wearing
her mask
or wearing her mask i mean like there's
a thousand people dying a day
yeah like lele pons should be making
everyone wear masks at her [ __ ]
halloween party this weekend you know
what i mean like that
like wait why does lele pons have more
responsibility than the president
because the president is mocking someone
he's just joking
the president has had dozens of rallies
people packed together
many of them not wearing masks whose
fault is that no i agree but i'm saying
like who's more responsible tana
mongoose party or the president
you just asked me like oh he's made fun
of this woman that's wrong and i was
like oh well making fun of someone isn't
as serious as like
gatherings of people okay well he does
that
do you want a president that packs ten
so if you think tandem
if who'd you say lele pogba do you think
lele pons is
is bad imagine having a party with 30
000 people packed together i wonder who
is worse who's more disliked lately
pawns or donald trump
because people really don't like lately
yeah but i think even donald trump she
has a lot she deleted amanda cerny's
like youtube videos back in the day
yeah i remember that i remember that's
crazy that was that was pretty exciting
no one's talking about that and they're
still like lazy pawns it's like she
literally deleted
girls like social media i don't know how
she got away with that [ __ ] was crazy
poor man
i don't even know her that well but like
okay hang on
um do you if you do you believe that we
should be racing to
renewable energy as soon as possible yes
don't even know what it means
that's why i'm voting for joe biden i
love reasonable energy
like what the [ __ ] if do you want a
president that act to read that reads
his intelligence
briefings yes
dissertation there about this is really
important to me but okay why don't we
say this with hd do you want a president
where people this is entertaining i mean
we just found out you don't know what
climate change is that's pretty epic
yeah but i don't think people tune into
this to hear your political
well i don't give a [ __ ] because today
it's important i'm
you got nominated for that podcast on
there
award winning i wish i could say that
the only one once
no really they just always put you up
because i still don't [ __ ] off i
don't know i don't [ __ ] reach i don't
give them the reach around that they
need you guys are also the only one that
doesn't have a company underneath you
when it says everyone else is like 13
yours says
baby is it i'll completely everything we
do is self-owned
self-run because i don't i don't
oh we're clapping for that
i'm proud that's i don't like them
that's why you're so rich that's the
problem yeah it is a big reason because
i'm not paying for it seriously
you know my last podcast company podcast
one was taking fifty percent
yeah [ __ ] that fifty percent because all
they do is like we'll build you a set
we'll do this
i built my set i recorded it i edited it
wait so what were they taking fifty
percent for what were they doing i guess
the ads i guess they were giving back
ad agencies take at most twenty percent
yeah they were
they took fifty percent of it but i did
everything else and then they let me
they fired me for being not making
enough money
like fired you yeah they're getting
fifty percent
and i did everything but then they try
to come back and i tell you this t
they try to come back and be like hey
what if we keep giving you ads and we'll
take 50
of that but like you edit and upload
your podcast and i was like
because i i did i just they uploaded it
for me and i don't know how to upload
but
crazy anyways that is straight that
that's what
these middlemen they're all the same
they're so rotten
so yeah um do you want a president
that spends less time tweeting for
example and i wouldn't normally
comply i don't complain people are
allowed to use twitter but here for
example
donald trump's most prolific day on
twitter was june 5th
2020 when he tweeted 200 times in a
single day
if if you allocate two minutes to every
tweet
that's 6.6 hours that's the president
who's spending on nearly seven hours on
his phone tweeting
can i i'm just like again not voting for
trump don't support trump but i'm just
saying to play like devil's advocate
like does the president really do that
much i think it's mostly like the people
around him that do
yes the president should be working i
don't think so because also joe biden
is old and racist too it's like we're
kind of just going wait hold on
hold on hold on i i feel like joe biden
racism is overblown there's definitely a
video of him saying he doesn't want
black people in
it was schools with his kids like
definitely is that right check that back
check it we have to fact check
i saw i saw this video i haven't seen
that it's a thousand percent out there
okay well let's let's fact check that
because i don't want any
as as joe likes to say malarkey
joe biden but if you want to have a
racism olympics i mean trump definitely
wins
i don't know well well joe biden admits
that systemic racism is a thing
he's his running mate his vice president
is black
i think that's why he picked her to be
like oh look i'm not racist forget that
crime act in 1984 i got a blah like
that's what people do
that's like when you call someone racist
are we talking about because he like as
you said he's old are we talking about
something that happened 40 years ago you
know what i mean
well i think what you're referring to is
in 1977
he said that a non-orderly racial
integration policy would cause his
children to grow up in a racial jungle
how long ago was that 1977. can you
crunch the numbers on that that was uh
50 or no 40 40 43 years ago 43 years ago
i mean are you so the guy so it's not i
mean
first of all read that quote again dan
well and this isn't even
this is the quote taken out of context i
can't really attribute
so he said something that was possible
about the whole debate with bussing
remember
this was like a thing earlier in the
primary camel camila harris who's now
his vp got all testy with him at one of
the debates about how
he wasn't for uh busing children
from minor neighborhoods so this was 43
years ago so
we should be president we should have a
43 year old president not someone 43
years ago
saying black people shouldn't be around
my kids like that's not what it's crazy
to even
think of that's literally what he said
that's like the overall
like justification of it look like i
said i voted for buying i'm not trying
to be like oh whatever but i'm just
saying like at the same time well listen
if the only perfect people should run
then nobody will ever run for
president i agree but don't use like
tweeting it's like well
what wait what is one of these women
what does tweeting have to do i would
rather a president that's focused on
doing his [ __ ] job than spending
seven hours on twitter
you know what like i said i love him but
i really don't want my president like
grabbing me at rallies you know what i
mean like that's kind of like who's here
there's look that video up yeah roping
he's literally
groping girls and yeah what about
grabbing by the [ __ ]
donald trump okay if you want to talk
about that that was a long time ago this
is this
43 years ago this campaign biden's going
around like literally like feeling like
young like it was like teenagers look it
up
and this is true and that's really
[ __ ] up my endorsement
that literally left a bad taste in my
mouth again i would have provided if you
want to know but i'm just saying like
okay i'm getting there
i'm getting there the other side that
hey like both of these people are kind
of okay so one per so one president
spent seven hours a day on twitter but
the other one
maybe said something racist 43 years ago
bottom line you should vote for everyone
based on what's important to you like
gay rights trans rights like that that's
what i'm
doing women's rights are important to me
you don't you think you don't think a
president should spend seven
hours on twitter but then there's people
who like deportation like obviously like
deep like that like immigrants like daca
like you know he just
i mean i heard this from my my hair
stresser but she was saying like you
just signed a bill
yeah because she's really big into
hispanic rights and stuff like that joe
biden is pro
daca what he said one of the first
things he'll do just like admitted like
what was like 400 000 or something like
daca people like
dreamers saying like they're cool like
donald trump was trying to pick daca
people
out this whole during obama it was like
three million and during trump it's been
like
you're mixing up deportation and daca
you don't daca is different than
deportation
i'm going to look it up he just fell for
daca people clearing wait you have to
stop
i'm gonna deportation
do you understand that are you kidding
me david doper came over here on daca
he's a dreamer he came over here when he
was in the nine in the early night
isn't is it obama isn't daca obama's
initiation no david's a dream
yes it was it was i i don't really know
what trish was talking about
oh my god i just don't know and trump
tried to kick all the daca people out
all right
i just looked it up there's an article
from august this year
august 28th that's how david told stance
is how he came over here on the dreamer
act he was a dreamer he doesn't have
social security protecting dreamers
stalker protects dreams i think you
might be confusing
yeah yeah oh my god well let me show you
romp wanted to kick
daca people dreamers out of the country
that was his whole thing he was saying
get the [ __ ] out
obama made daca just sign something over
i'm gonna try and find it he just signed
something clearing everybody the girl
that does my hair she's like really big
into like hispanic right that's her
thing she's mexican her husband's
mexican and she just said he just signed
over a bunch of things
again i'm just trying to put both sides
because you're literally doing one side
being like
you're wrong about all the dreamers but
you're wrong i'm wrong everybody
that was like a central point of his
platform is that he wanted to kick out
dreamers he was ending daca
he said i am ending daca for four years
he said
i am ending daca and joe biden said the
first thing i will do
is that i will protect daca he said we
are going to take care of daca we are
going to take care of dreamers it's
working right now we are negotiating
different aspects of immigration
immigration law trump said but we are
working very hard on the daca program
and you will be i think very happy over
the course of next year because i feel
the same way about it as you do
that's what he said after trying to
cancel daca his entire administration
because it's a policy that obama created
dan fact-checked that i can't allow
business i'm gonna be
a fact-checked well yeah we can allow
misinformation we need to
let the people know what's actually true
yeah but you're doing all one-sided this
is like not one-sided
all i'm doing is listing things that i
personally care about and i think most
thing you're like asking and like being
like do you care about this the way
you're presenting it is very one-sided i
said do you want a president doesn't
spend
six hours a day on twitter i don't don't
care
about that okay well i do 24 hours it
doesn't matter like
when you're less productive yes it does
super productive and i'm on tick-tock
you're not the president you work on
fifth grade
you work on tick-tock i'm so productive
doing other things besides tick-tock but
i'm constantly on tick-tock like i'm
doing other things you're not the
[ __ ] president i could be
easily about 35 do you know what climate
change is no
okay does trump know climate changes
maybe not
you don't know what he knows likely he
doesn't maybe that's a good point
dan are you able to find any facts on
this what are we doing
i'm i'm dan's firing i'm giving an
honest try to find what you're talking
about trisha i i can't find what you're
talking about dan always says this is
why
nobody likes the h3 podcast because dan
zack and ian ruin it
why don't you have females are you
misogynistic how come you don't have
females people could argue that too
there's no females working for you guys
why are you attacking me right now i'm
not attacking i'm like
pointing out facts if you want to point
out facts okay do you want a president
that spends less time on twitter
i do okay trisha apparently wants
president to spend some more time on
twitter i couldn't care less
like who cares you can spend time on
twitter not six hours a day okay 200
tweets a day is [ __ ] neurotic
and all have you ever tweeted 200 times
in a day maybe i don't know
no i'm sure i have at one point
literally nobody is tweeted 200 times a
day
except [ __ ] maniacs i mean that's
your stance you should be arguing better
points than that
oh i have didn't have you been paying
attention the past like 20 minutes
unfortunately i feel like everyone's
tuned out this is not the asian podcast
this is front of me this is the fun one
this is the one that gets the views
people like the popping conversation and
we've been stuck
for the past 45 minutes are you
comfortable with your president calling
for his political opponents to be locked
up
what are you comfortable with your
president calling for political
opponents to be locked up oh my god what
is the right answer that you're going to
say yes no i don't know i couldn't care
less about that i'm telling you what i
care about
i don't care about that i personally
don't think that my president should be
calling for his political opponents to
be locked up
so if you agree with the things that
i've said here today then i urge you all
to go
vote today is the voting day and it's
more important than ever
if you disagree with the things they
said then go vote too yeah
vote for who you want and who you
think's going to do the best first i
agree
if you disagree with the things they
said go vote too because democracy only
works
when people vote this is horrible this
is like watching ladies oh
endorsements it's just like crazy also
if you work in iowa
if you live in iowa arizona ohio north
carolina georgia florida
nevada texas minnesota wisconsin
michigan pennsylvania new hampshire
your vote matters more than mine because
the electoral college is [ __ ]
stupid as [ __ ] so you should especially
go vote because
for some [ __ ] reason your vote
matters more than mine and trisha's
so go vote pennsylvania michael keaton
pennsylvania especially michael keaton
get the [ __ ] out there involved get him
on the podcast
yes really i would cry can i tell you
he's the one and if you disagree
go vote for donald trump and that's fine
but everybody vote okay that's it
yeah we can't get michael keaton he
doesn't like the founder
okay so why can't you get that really
upset you the whole political thing it
doesn't upset me at all see
uh this is what you're doing this is gas
lighting when you're like that really
upset you intended at all i'm having a
conversation over the podcast
i think you fooled me and everybody
watching you're like
[ __ ] you don't have women on your
podcast
i mean you don't if you're gonna play
like that round it's like okay well you
also like
donald trump donald trump such a boys
club
you guys are basically donald trump you
are basically the whites the right side
and white side of this because it's like
you have all
the people that protect you and you
protect them and everyone else like it's
like can't come in can't infiltrate
you're like what's the
deal with jack's films like who [ __ ]
cares like you protect all these people
dan protects you oh i'm trying to find
what you're saying
i can't find it like it's crazy like
it's so
insane i don't care i'm not upset i
don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
let's all right how are you feeling uh
oh let's talk about drama
let's talk about john why did he start
delete the tweet that he did about you
did you see that video why did he delete
it oh we should watch that let's pull it
up
we watched it and i was like why why did
you delete it i don't know because he's
not offensive
he's a i don't know why because he's a
little [ __ ]
bad for him i think he might be maybe
something wrong with him like a little
off and so i feel like we shouldn't make
fun of him because
i think he's a little off right i mean
you have a good point because i do
and i don't i say this was piece of
peace and love and i know i'm not like
qualified and i should and i'm not like
diagnosing him you know yada yada yada
yeah but like i do think that he
probably has some kind of personality
disorder
i don't think his personality disorder i
think there's like a little bit of like
he's just a little slow
like maybe learning or something oh i
think he's actually smart
i don't think so he confuses things a
lot and i'm like and i don't think he
does it on purpose
like he's trying to be funny and i'm
like oh i think he's like maybe some
sort of like
learning handicap he says he has
dyslexia i have i have some dyslexia
yeah but that's
it's beyond dyslexia that's why i kind
of feel bad like
i think he might have some kind of
personality disorder i mean who doesn't
really you know everyone has a little
bit of something but but anyway here's
the video that he removed about me
that's a good one
another one well so but i mean i guess
the whole joke is that he's making fun
of my tourettes
which i guess some people think is like
yeah but it's not tourette's
tourette's is like when you i have
tourette syndrome no tourette's is when
you're like
[ __ ] this just isn't that tourette's i
don't know you can actually
yeah you're right i shouldn't get so
there's obviously it's a scale right i
have tourette's syndrome i have a mild
case of tourette syndrome that's why i'm
all ticky with my face and stuff
um okay so it's not custom why do they
always say it's like cussing and things
swear words like well that's
like the high that's like the super uh
on the sliding scale that's the really
severe case of tourettes tourettes is
like
an extreme case of ocd uh characterized
by
like vocal tics so mine is very most
people tourette's just go like
you might hear during a podcast you hear
stan's like stuff like that
i never heard that yeah it's quiet but
then you have the really extreme
version of tourette's which is usually a
combo of other kind of neurological
things is is when you end up with people
who are screaming obscenities but that's
very weird
i've never heard you say this once you
have tourette's yeah i've talked about
it a lot
but it's obviously i don't talk about
every episode but i've talked about it
i'm very open about it i've never heard
you talk about it so he's making fun of
the fact that after he knows i have
tourette's
so that's kind of he's making fun of my
wonderful do you care though
no i yeah i don't care but i just think
it's pathetic that like that's his gag
right a happy
you know what i mean right then then he
but then dan why aren't you laughing i
mean that's kind of good that's kind of
funny
but then the other thing he does is he
calls elo horse
i don't get that is it because her face
yeah he thinks he thinks like a long
like
oh and so then he's always been like i
don't want to do that but then he does
it
in this one yeah he goes ela i don't
think i saw that ending
so here he goes over like either we have
to fire him or something
it's too much laughing cut it off and
then here's uh
hilah as a horse should we fire him as a
horse
i mean he's not funny so we know that
but i think like i said i think that
something is like
wrong with them like slow whenever
people go for like not to even be
whatever but i feel like when people go
for like low things like when people go
like for instance if they call me like
fat like that's such an easy thing
and like i don't know your trust thing
but like the face thing or whatever like
that's like a
low blow you know it's not like smart or
anything you know what i mean so i feel
like with that he's like kind of off i
think he's just like
a little slow himself in the sense that
he doesn't really get that that's not
like
you know what i mean like i think he's
just i think he's just trying to be as
mean as possible because he thinks it'll
upset me
like he thinks that him calling my wife
a horse will really upset me do you
think he
he thinks it's light-hearted because
something no no no he's trying to be his
mean as well
can i just tell you with our beef on
twitter like i actually like
i was just trying to push as much as i
can i never was like i never like hated
you i never was like oh my god let me
just piss him off
yeah but i think you were actually like
taking offense to things i said
no i wasn't at all you never took about
anything i said on twitter
not at all so why'd you unfollow me
because i didn't want to see your
[ __ ] vagina
but you didn't i
why is your butthole so large or
something and i was like oh so you like
yeah you commented on it no i literally
i literally
unfollowed you because i was tired of
seeing you naked on my
and like not just naked like but that's
you commenting no i messaged you i said
i said hey trisha peace and love i have
to unfollow that you were commenting on
like
my gaping butthole yeah maybe it was fun
i probably left a funny comment
so then i was like oh okay and then you
like talked about my vagina on h3 before
before i was like too much
there was one photo wait i get it i'm
just saying like you were actually
i remember you would like text moses in
like the group chat and be like
dude what the [ __ ] why is she tweeting i
love you in hebrew like you were getting
like actually like offended by stuff i
was doing and i was like
or like that i said he had like a well
i'm not and okay i don't know
well what my point is is like maybe he
thinks it's like you guys have this beef
it's like a joke like it looks like a
joke
outside he he hates me but you're gonna
i know from people that know him
no he he doesn't hate you yes he does
why would he go why would he go through
that effort for someone he hates he
wants your attention
well he might my attention that much is
true but he does genuinely
hate me and vice versa i think you like
the attention because you dressed up as
keem with the keemstar puppet like i
feel like you also want his attention
i don't want his attention i just want
to make fun of him sometimes because i
because i think he i i just i really
think that you just like him for real
i really just he's probably the only
person in the world that i really
dislike
because i think he's just a really toxic
force on youtube
and he causes a lot of grief in people's
life that otherwise shouldn't have to
deal with
yeah i think he does like like he just
he he's just such a negative force
the reason i have my only issue with him
was like when i asked him like privately
a couple times to stop like hey can you
just stop talking about me and i was
like through private text or whatever
just like texting who's texting my phone
number
and he like shared those dm's and
screenshots and he goes she's not
telling me the truth about [ __ ] gabby
hannah like i'm gonna expose him
like stop like and he wouldn't and he
literally said i said can you please
stop he's like no when i was like
what the [ __ ] like what crazy person
when you ask someone to stop it's not
funny anymore because he continues to do
it because he
i do think he's kind of a sadist in that
way he's like when he sees that you're
wounded or vulnerable
then he he digs in i'll read because i
was like at a really like breaking point
and i literally said something like hey
my mental health is like really not good
now like i was trying to be like really
nice about it because i really wanted
him to stop it was giving me well you
know he thinks mental health is fake he
thinks that people just say that to get
out of things he's repeatedly said
that mental health doesn't exist and
people just use it as an excuse
this one is like he kept asking me to
send me proof and i'm like i'm [ __ ]
drained i don't trust you i asked you
not to leak information i shouldn't be
talking about that trust me how i'm not
out to get you i said you're escalating
very
serious problem can you leave me alone
because i want to know the [ __ ] truth
and i said that's all i ask you're not
the police you're not here you don't
you're exploiting all this it's sick
it's sick just stop
police are involved do you want views
i'm asking you kindly he goes exploiting
trish i get no views talking about you
and gabby that's facts i said then just
stop i'm asking you he goes no
i said you call me mentally ill paranoid
this is insane good luck with all these
fake things it's insane good luck with
that i can't believe it's what he's like
i reached out then this is like i
reached out to shane to back up your
story and he didn't respond like yeah
like this is when shane's going through
his [ __ ] i'm like like he's gonna
respond
i said okay what do you want me to do
has a lot of [ __ ] going on then he goes
uh what are you saying you're texting me
and then i said all this stuff like the
private conversations he goes why don't
you just make peace with gabby like he's
texting me he's like a crazy person he
has a kid
and like this thing and he's like asking
me what this thing and i said hey like
i said i this is like serious whatever
he's like this is way too stressful like
you have to whatever
and then i said i said i'm like she's
harassing me i'm blocking you now this
is insane
i said no normal person would ever get
involved with you and this is weird wish
you well hopefully you realize no one
cares
he's like convince me gabby is stalking
you proof please and i'm like okay and
then i just blocked him because he's
[ __ ] crazy but i asked him to stop
i'm like i'm not wow yeah and then you
blo and then he forces you to block him
and he goes look trisha blocked
yes and then showed all the things and i
was like i just don't believe you and
i'm like why
i sent him look at all this i sent him
like documents like restraining orders
like gag orders like all this stuff that
i've like sent
and he's like he goes i'm giving you
advice like all this crazy stuff and i
was just like can you just stop
talking about me and he wouldn't yeah
anyways yeah exactly
he's crazy he's a girl i mean he's like
grown and like when you ask someone
privately to stop like it's actually
affecting me and they don't that's like
[ __ ] weird if you're going back on
twitter and you want attention whatever
that's one thing because i've done that
too like i don't mind that but like
the thing is like he
the thing is like he's been lot saying
lies about me for a long time like
saying i stole money [ __ ] like that like
not funny that i already disapproved
you know he's from who from a video game
company we did a collab with
he said i was supposed to use that i was
like no there's our money and stuff like
that right so like he's literally
he's doing everything he can to like
ruin my career or whatever he's been
doing that for years so
it's not it's not funny it's just so you
really do just like him because i don't
think there's
one yeah okay yeah i really do dislike
keemstar i just like him too
thank you we can agree on that i love
that that's all right that's the friend
box
but we just bonded um he's just awful
he's just a bad person like
but i think most people would agree that
calling someone's uh wife a horse is
is right but like i said to that like
you did call
tana twinkie like i think that's like
something he thinks is funny it's like
gross
well in the context of a instagram
reality video
i mean i agree it was rude but like her
outfit
was yellow and it was in the context of
her like
morphing her body but he's just
insulting my wife to get to me
but he's doing it just that because she
doesn't look like a horse like everyone
yeah feel
so hot by the way oh no i know she
that's why it doesn't it doesn't bother
me because elo is beautiful
but my friends are really jealous of you
by the way for ila they're like wow you
look so [ __ ] hot like why is she with
you
like they literally say that to me
actually i'm like oh my god this is like
it's not weird
but it's like ela's very like you know
she's not very like out there like just
trying to like show her tits and stuff
but i was like she's so [ __ ] hot like
damn like who said that
i can't tell you is it someone i know no
you don't know this one
they watch the podcast though and
they're like she's just so hot like why
is why she with ethan like she can do so
much better like what the [ __ ]
that's fine well we're very happy like
obviously that's what i'm saying is she
obviously is not a woman well now well
now that he's started that though
people are always tweeting and
commenting and it's like this whole
thing where people call it
that she's ugly no i agree but like but
like you know
whatever it's just it's like it's [ __ ]
up like why
why does she have to see everyone
calling her a horse on all of her posts
is it like bad like i think it's just
like his people you know what i mean
like
no it is i'm just saying people call me
a whale like they always like
tweet mo that's like pictures look i'm
not i'm not i'm just saying
whatever we agree we agree we don't need
to argue about concerns from you i've
got a lot of
whale and corpse and like all this stuff
like that
yeah i'm sorry i mean it's fine i'm
saying like that is like the least of
the keemstar evil i feel
and if she did look ugly like a horse
like it would be one thing but she does
you guys need to make the next bigger on
teddy fresh i have to like pull my neck
it's like
it hurts me and like gives me lots of
smoke i also have really fat fingers i
found out i have a size nine
wedding ring finger that's so huge
why are you doing wedding rings i was
literally gonna just buy one for myself
but they don't make them in my size at
the store it's so embarrassing
what let me see your fat finger it's not
that big
what do you know what size well you have
small hands but do you know what size
your fingers are
like a regular guy size like a size
eight mine's a size nine and they don't
carry
them at all like the biggest size to
carry for women are still one of those
rings i can get like something
custom-made but i want to go to a store
and pick a ring out and buy it you know
what i mean it's like they're like ma'am
you're
like ma'am i hate to tell you this but
your fingers are way too [ __ ] fat for
this story
literally literally we were they have
plus size ring stores
they should they really should i was
really sad we went to this really fancy
like resort
place and they had like these these
stones that they make there and they're
like fifteen thousand dollars was this
ring or something i wanted and he's like
well they can stretch it a little bit
like didn't even get past my knuckle i
was so sad he's like well we can get it
to you in like two
weeks when she has to like reconstruct a
whole new one for your fat finger and i
was like no it's not the same like i
want one now
it's just [ __ ] that they do that
anyways i have really fat fingers it
really sucks oh my god one other thing
if you lost a bunch of weight do you
think your fingers yeah no because i
used to be like my skinniest was 150
which is still kind of big but was 150
and i still had really pudgy fingers
back then too
interesting you could just have big ass
finger balls yeah but you have really
small fingers and hands
yeah why is that that's interesting i
don't know
everything else is uh i like them they
look like a little boy
okay okay you asked me too about a
mukbang
yeah i think you know what's really
popular where i feel like goes viral and
also like whatever it's not that i like
love this food because i really don't
but like if you type in like muck
fingers eating crab legs you need to get
those jungle
tablets no but then do the alfredo sauce
i don't love it either but with like
alfredo sauce
no i can't do seafood we'll have to do
something else like
spicy yeah i want to do spices i can't
do spicy though oh you can't
but i would do it for the show funny no
i can't do crabs i can't do seafood
it's just i can't do it you have to just
do it for the like a thumbnail like that
you can't
do the crabs the way he said it was like
light
yeah i just can't do it let's talk about
drama okay you've
no barely well hold on the bit the best
one
hold on well we have like ace family ah
ace family what's new with them i think
they were i don't know you did like a
whole thing about them and then james
so this is what i want to talk about is
james charles which we didn't talk about
on video
so you made five videos about ace family
am i still on frame dan
yeah why do you sit like that you just
want to look as unflattering as possible
you love being ugly i feel
it's fun because you don't have to worry
about looking good you know
yeah but you're not an ugly person and
you just like to make yourself ugly for
what reason
more relatable some people don't know
you're relatable
it's not like oh he's so he's so
you're unrelatable you look more
intimidating that way you look better
looking and you know you look like
no because i was comfortable let me can
i tell you something i used to be so
insecure about my looks
back in like high school like when you
were you told me you're like a diver or
something right you're like a swimmer
like you did i always thought i was yeah
i was fit actually back then but i was
i was uh i thought i was very ugly and i
would just stare at myself in the mirror
and i was like
i would just like hate look at myself
and i just hated how i looked
and i would if i saw a picture of myself
it would ruin my whole [ __ ] day
wow and i wouldn't i would just avoid i
wouldn't take photos i wouldn't look at
pictures of myself because
i would just i just hated i thought i
was so [ __ ] hideous
and so i said you know what this was
somewhere around the end of high school
i said i can't live like this it's
ruining
my it's just ruining it's ruining me
right yeah like i
there was times there was a window in my
backyard of the house i grew up in that
was like really reflective
and i would go out there and just stare
at it's so weird like just stare at
myself
and just like cry oh my god
and so i said i'm not gonna look in the
mirror anymore
i'm not gonna look at photos i'm not
gonna look in the mirror because it just
ruins my [ __ ] day whoa and
it doesn't matter what i look like i
look like what i look like and so i went
like an entire year
oh my god that's so intense without even
looking at an image of myself
or looking in the mirror and then
somehow i felt better i came out of that
end of that year
and i stopped i literally just stopped
giving a [ __ ]
about how i looked and now i don't care
at all
i think you probably need a therapy
instead because it sounds like you
didn't resolve the issue because now
you're trying to be as ugly as possible
like doing the unflattering photos you
always do
and the angles i think there's like a
deeper issue you're like if i look ugly
it's like the what about bob where if
you fake you're having a heart attack
you're not having a heart attack you're
like i'm going to be ugly as possible so
people can't make fun of me for being
i'm not ugly all the time i'm
comfortable being yeah i'm comfortable
being like this
you're always showing like the belly gag
the chin well i think it's funny because
it's like people always go how could you
show yourself like that and i think
that's funny because you would rather
people
say that about you than like oh he's so
ugly or like look at that angle well
sure there might be something to that
but i post normal
photos of myself all the time well i'm
so sorry i feel like have you ever been
in therapy
yeah are you in it now i'm not in it now
i was earlier this year oh okay good for
you yeah
i think i mean that's like a that's a
deep rooted that's sad i mean because
that's like not knowing well it was pity
it's like
it was really sad at the time but it
doesn't bother me anymore
because like i hate the way i look too
like i hate my body and i feel fat but i
never look at it like oh you're
disgusting i can't look at myself like
i'm like oh sometimes i look hot you
know so to have that where it's like
in you you just hate you're looking at
yourself it ruins your day it's like an
intense yeah no it was awful that's why
i was like i'm just not gonna look
at i'm not gonna look at myself anymore
and now but it was like before i
couldn't even look at a photo
and now you know i just but like i'm on
camera you know that's my living right
so
you look skinnier than me but can i tell
you why you look skinnier than me is
because your shoulders are small you
have small shoulders and i'm very
broad shoulder so i look like i'm like
twice your size okay when in reality
whatever you have to tell yourself no no
we're like the same size we've
established what you're like 220. i feel
like i'm like 220 now so i feel like
we're the same size
but i'm like significantly taller okay
i'm just saying damn i mean i'm just
saying you're trying to say we're the
same size
right how tall are you i'm five eleven
how tall are you
i'm five eleven as well no you're not
i'm not even close
you're like five eight i might buy
three i have flat five three
and you weigh the same amount as me and
you're saying we're the same size that's
why
i'm gonna have a hundred years i feel
like can you stand up well i have my
shoes on let me know
without shoes oh yeah you're pretty
small i think i feel like i can't even
see us
see my head's not even framing i'm such
a monster giant
how tall are you five eleven are you
yeah um i can't see that well
anyway let's talk about that well you're
just saying hey you're like hey we're
the same size
and i'm like well i am like you know six
inches taller
it's okay i'm a little chunky monkey but
i'm trying to lose weight now i'm gonna
go get a salad after this for real
although we are getting pizza tonight so
i'm gonna have the salad for lunch i'm
trying to like limit i'm saving my pizza
token for tomorrow i'm so excited for
the reaction
oh oh i'm gonna drink i'm gonna eat
pizza and i'm gonna pray
oh oh what if it's bad though and then
you're like then i'm gonna drink more
yeah you just die [ __ ] well be careful
don't do too much god i'm so stressed
about tomorrow
i've been waiting for it for so long oh
you're excited election
yeah yeah let's talk about james charles
so you made five videos about ace family
being like blah blah blah
and then what is it that you said about
james in one of the videos
it was such a blowout comment i was
making five videos about the ace family
i was coming for austin
and like austin is so narcissistic
self-absorbed people i'm like the only
other person i can think on this
platform like that is james charles
that's all i said
and then i continued blasting austin and
james charles like
what was the comment do you have it yeah
we got it right here so james charles
leaves a comment on your tick tock
from his tick tock and says keep my name
out of your mouth you do not know me
which is so psycho by the way for him to
come like you would just you
like as a public figure you should just
really like move on and ignore that
yeah it's so weird even if you're like
oh trish is a [ __ ] she's wrong whatever
yada yada
yeah that's whatever the concept like he
came and he left a comment
leave my name out of your mouth like
what are you like tupac
it was so that's what i was asking what
the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah yeah you have to send me a straight
[ __ ] yeah i hate when you should drive
by his house
and do what drive by it's like hey
what's that no
if he wants to get street let's drive by
okay
let's [ __ ] you're not leaving no
no we're not doing that no no
let's drive by let's get up to homies
let's get the homies together
james is just very nervous let's get the
[ __ ] homies and ride
he always complains about not having a
boyfriend and i'm just like well maybe
like evaluate why
people don't want it james charles
really not getting any
no that is so sad it's so
awful and he's so rich and famous like
how could he not get but that's how you
know your personality
sucks when you're at that level like
harvey weinstein
even o.j are getting dates now and he
cuts his wife's head
off well that wasn't proven like he well
it is kind of
um doj definitely killed her
i don't know it's like no he did he was
pretty found guilty in a silver
civil court okay well that just goes a
test to james charles personality yeah
can you imagine would you go on a date
with oj if you weren't with moses
can i just say i used to have a little
crush on rosie simpson but he's a
handsome guy he's a big fan
but knowing what you know now would you
go on a date without i did a music video
dedicated to oj simpson i should
probably delete it before this comes out
because i did a whole music video saying
how much i love about jason and it was
really
bad like a couple years ago why i really
wanted to date him because he was
getting out of prison and i was like oh
maybe i should [ __ ] you're crazy
subconsciously i do think i wanted to
die like i was like if i get murdered
like
do you know what i mean like death by uh
suicide by oj
yeah like if he was the one can i tell
you that's why i used to only date
famous people because i thought if i
died real
oh you have extensions on no these are
permanent though like you can pull them
and shower because i saw your
because it looks good um i got these new
yeah these are in for the next month
so you want to kill yourself by o.j
simpson i don't want to kill myself i'm
saying if if i'm gonna die i'd rather be
die at the hands of a famous person
um you know it's a little more iconic to
my story
to my legacy as opposed to moses killing
me it's not that iconic as if like o.j
simpson killed me
yeah you'd be forgotten if moses killed
you i don't think it'd be forgotten it
just wouldn't be as
big well that's a fair point right you
make a persuasive argument i'm a twitter
headline for like a day if moses tells
me if oj does it i'm getting movies
maybe
yeah exactly yeah cool anyways i just do
think he's sexy
a serial killer sometimes are sexy and
that's what's [ __ ] up
i have a friend that i think might be a
serial killer well i don't think he's
killed anyone yet but i think he might
eventually
what are the signs he's well just all of
them
does he does he hurt animals
no that's like then is that the number
one time i don't think he does that
tortures animals
i think he's just on the path of maybe
if you see him hurting animals you
should call it
oh my god no if i really thought he was
gonna kill someone i'd call somebody
i think he's just good looking i think
that's why i think he's a serial killer
because he's like too good looking to be
single
i can't believe james cheryl's gonna get
a dick yeah james charles though like
he's just
so self-absorbed to leave that comment
to be like don't talk about
which what like my name out of your
mouth like he's literally only famous
for drama like he's not he's talented
but that's not why people like him you
know what i mean he just leaches on to
these
tips there's all this other james
charles t that kind of surprised me
he uh in a video uploaded by noah oh
this is one you were talking about okay
where he said he would kill uh james uh
shane dawson which [ __ ] ads you're
ruining my show
i have youtube premium but it's not the
right account i'm logged in okay
sure you do i swear to god i have
youtube premium i'm not poor
i don't have youtube and i'm i'm not
poor let me log into my youtube premium
account
okay bougie can we get joe rogan on the
podcast oh no
i problem on his podcast to promote the
show sure can you have your pr people
reach out be like trisha wants to come
on yeah podcast
i feel like he's a big podcast joe rogan
is he
yeah he's big he's more bigger front
enemies or h3
well the whole h3 collective universe is
more popular am i in the universe can i
go
can i go to the streamies on your behalf
and accept it oh that'd be [ __ ]
awesome
definitely okay
is there not a time stamp we have to
watch a whole james charles video for
the team
where's the [ __ ] time stamp you know
what this is kind of a big deal i know
it's kind of like petty feel like it's a
game or whatever but that [ __ ] mirror
kill [ __ ]
is is intense kiss marry kill kiss mary
kept
tom holland oh i have a mega theory that
he's gay
who is that what's his name i thought
you know him he's super famous on tick
tock
he's painting like a charlie's sister or
something
what you don't know him he's like super
no okay maybe he's not a big deal
okay gay or straight
we all know we'll kill it i mean i guess
like marry tom holland and
kiss liam payne that's easy good
question
first of all all those people in that
car and i can't wait for their
cancellation tobuscus style you know
what i mean just like
where is ray william johnson that's
gonna be them that kid on this side is
going to be ray william johnson like
being like
where harry yeah wait what's his name
larry i think what a name
where you like larry my grandfather's
name no shader
grandfather wait why don't you like
larry i like larry what's he do
i don't even know maybe i don't know but
he likes teddy fresh so i like him oh
bias you can't be biased like that he
isn't a car with james charles which by
by association i'm gonna just cancel him
anyway he's basically gooblers
gobblers what is that
goobler what's his name goebbels he's
gobbles
what's gobo he was like he worked with
hitler
no but that's what's scary about this is
james charles will actually probably
kill someone because he's a psychopath
no he's not
no like okay i have a good grasp of
people who are actual
psychotic people and him and gabby
hannah are psychotic people
and i don't know they're murderers look
i get it
i love how keep star your enemies are
like they're psycho they're gonna kill
people and then keemstar's like i get
why you will call your
your wife a horse wait oh yeah well
calling on a horse is like
i mean not a horse so what do you think
they're gonna do and he's not gonna
really kill james charles
he's playing against shane yeah shane
dawson
can i just say like james gives me those
serial killer energy
yeah but he's oh it's gonna replay in 10
years it's going to replay and people
this happens to me all the time
tricia well i'll tell you what i just
called carl before anyone else i was
like this guy is like low-key pervy and
they're like no that's a [ __ ] mormon
family man
though huh i feel like you say that
about everybody what about you i didn't
say anything
you said i'm like once before
not that way i didn't i didn't mean like
loki i will tell you what if james
charles doesn't get filleted soon
we're gonna find some frozen dicks in
his freezer because this guy needs to
get laid desperately
the other issue is is like him talking
about like a jeffrey dahmer style i hate
that he always talks about like straight
guys sliding into his dna it's like why
do you need to put that out there like
what are you who are you trying to like
flex by the way this i just want to say
before we move on to that
this didn't offend me at all it's not
offensive i think it's totally overblown
he's just playing a game he says i don't
like shane that's all he's saying i
don't like shane
okay james no one likes you so good luck
i mean you know how i feel about james
charles i'm just saying that [ __ ] was
he just you guys said [ __ ] america well
because you know what fast forward 10
years and you're going to play this and
they're like well trish was [ __ ]
right that guy's like a serial killer
all right he's a psychopath he's like
tati dude
he taught his like lawsuit now trying to
sue people for defamation
it is so hard yeah definitely like oh
you need to
you're disappeared just stay away from
the internet forever like go work a real
job like it's not
wrong with it like work at cracker
barrel who [ __ ] cares which by the
way went to cracker barrel over the
weekend
not sponsored but it was so [ __ ] good
wait so wait i'm getting trying to find
james's did he erase it
what the one about the the straight
no he did erase it it was on it was on
that one page i told you about here i've
got it here
james charles uh oh the oh wait so
here's the one he was on vogue portugal
if he's such a big deal why is he on
vogue portugal yeah what about vogue us
yeah exactly about james charles he goes
he's on the cover of vogue portugal
and then he he quote tweeted a
six-month-old tweet and said who's
laughing now babe
on who on a six-month-old tweet he said
hi i'm a talent
for vogue me and my team are very glad
we found this post because we needed
something to laugh
at just some
and then six months later quote tweeted
it said who's laughing now babe yeah
what tweet at me when you're on vogue
usa
he does i look i have no is like
literally he's done nothing to me other
than be like keep my name out of your
mouth which is like
you're accusing him of murder look
here's the they're not accusing him of
it
i'm just saying here are the warning
signs right he's obviously very insecure
that's why he's doing all this like get
some help treat your insecurities is
that a prostitute so you don't so you
don't
cut someone's dick off and put in your
freezer i don't mind that
i don't mind prostitutes no i'm saying
it's good i agree i said go
dude because this man is a ticking time
bomb until he gets some debt
remember when hugh grant [ __ ] that
prostitute over liz hurley when he was
dating her and he'd [ __ ] divine brown
off sunset boulevard
like hugh grant you don't remember that
oh i do vaguely remember that yeah who
grant was like damn can we get him on
the podcast people forget about this
eddie murphy picked up a trans
prostitute which you know
but he was ahead of his time back then
it was like whoa
he said he didn't know but i think he
knew i thought yeah oh
i mean i think he wanted brands like
women are like the hottest like to have
sex with them
is like the hottest like i love a tea
girl they're so [ __ ] hot there you go
eddie murphy agrees i tried to date one
on your bachelorette but you didn't
weed them out good enough for me you
didn't find good ones and then james oh
so
let's see james charles accused here's
this i wonder if it's a racer
oh here so he so james tweeted out
there's a famous tick-tock boy who every
time he fights with his girlfriend
snapchats me nudes and confesses his
love for me
then gets back together with her three
days later i finally decided to tell the
girl because she deserves better and she
blocked me
laughed my ass off yikes like first of
all why are you even sharing all this
information at one if it's true
i think i'll tell you why because he's
afraid he's gonna get outed
by that girl and he's trying to get
ahead of it who's gonna get outed
james if this girl's like james charles
is a freak and he's creeping on my
boyfriend
she blocked he's trying to reverse that
yeah he's trying to get ahead of it
yeah he said stop cheating on your
significant other it's awful and some of
us can't even get one boyfriend let
alone
like oh these are the kind of people i
can't stand like just [ __ ] stop being
so [ __ ] messy like damn
tell her and keep it private and if
there is something to expose he's so
scared of always getting exposed because
there's [ __ ] to expose on him i just
hear the worst things about him i don't
really care i don't know him but i still
don't like i don't like his
uh did you miss the memo keep his name
out of your mouth i'm gonna keep
you know when someone tells me that i
just do it ten times more i'm just like
it pisses me out like when you were like
hey stop tweeting me your [ __ ] i'm like
well here's my [ __ ] [ __ ] if you're
gonna keep saying it's ugly on your
podcast i'm gonna tweet it to you 20
more times yeah that's fine
thank you i just mute i mean i just
muted you
no i don't i think i thought i think i
followed you back on twitter now but i
mean
just because i don't want to see your
[ __ ] that's kinder like you should mute
someone that's why when someone
unfollows someone it's so intense
you know like damn i like to keep my
follower list slim though because i
don't want to feel like a follow [ __ ]
where i just follow like thousands of
people i don't think anyone cares that
much i don't think they're looking at
who you follow and how many well i'm
vain
i take my twitter very seriously oh
you're gonna look like a teddy bear okay
do people tell you that
no is that why you did teddy fresh
because you look like a little bear no
james charles accuses uh and then
there's oh yeah and then the toddy thing
is she's
tati westbrook is suing oh
first of all she's being accused of
fraud in a lawsuit filed by her business
partner
which is epic as [ __ ] tati yes tata tati
you guys all remember
by tati my sister by mother
more like buy grandma because she's a
grandma for youtube no
i'm just calling her old ow how old is
tati westbrook she's old she is like 40.
yeah so i'm saying if she's gonna say
bye sister i'm gonna say bye bye mom
yeah it's creepy that's grandma you
should i mean because that is weird
she's saying how james charles is like
17 or 18
38. so i agree yeah she was hanging out
with james
why is she making gossip about james
who's like 17.
bye-bye grandma because it's not even
her job she's a beauty guru like if
you're doing it it's like you know even
keemstar i guess it's like your job or
whatever but
it's like tatiana makes makeup videos so
to do that whole video about like this
18 year old was weird like sometimes
tata so she's being sued by her former
partner
over let's see gross negligence and
fraudulent
and duck inducement as it relates to
tati's vitamin line
halo beauty
it always comes around karma i've
experienced both bad and good karma and
it does come around every time
the lawsuit states that swanson agreed
to owning 50
of the nutritional supplement company
with tatin james owning the other half
however swanson alleges that just prior
to officially launching halo beauty 2018
james and tati came to him with an offer
give them two-thirds of the business in
exchange the west brooks would commit to
use halo beauty
as miss westbrook's umbrella brand for
all of her beauty launches
miss der swanson agreed to these terms
swanson further alleges that tati
promised her star power would result in
sales
describing how miss westbrook claimed
that the product did not matter
that she could sell a [ __ ] product to
her loyal followers
additionally swanson claims that tati
assured him that fellow youtube
personalities like jeffrey starr manny
mao meow man oh manny
mwah i think that is his name is that
really i think it's a good name
manny moi james charles and laura lee
would endorse the product claiming that
they turned down lucrative advertising
deals with rival
competitors sugar bear hair out of
loyalty to her
hair the documents note that her promise
of endorsements soured in 2019 miss
westbrook's claim
to influence was undercut when james
charles endorsed sugar bear hair
oh that's where all this is strong that
kind of explains right
that explains why she lost her mind
you're crazy the court document reads
on may 10 2019 miss westbrook posted
a video by sister accusing mr charles of
inappropriate sexual
conduct according to the lawsuit he went
behind swanson's back
to launch a separate beauty brand in
2019 under her own name
selling reusable beauty blenders and an
eyeshadow palette max
manufactured by seed beauty furthermore
swanson alleges
that west brooks began to plan the
launch of additional products for tati
beauty
including perfumes and other makeup
items without his knowledge
tati has not posted any videos on her
channel in four months
having stated that she is taking a break
so she sounds like if this is true
she [ __ ] that guy hard yeah greed
greed agreed greed i was playing
footsies with you
no you just kicked me yeah sorry it
wasn't put to you take it back
um that's [ __ ] insane she is evil
like i feel like james is just like
narcissistic self-absorbed like a little
prick
but i think she's like an actual evil
person like she actually has something
like
conniving and greedy and then now so
there's this channel without a crystal
ball
which i follow for drama oh yeah yeah
and uh
now she's suing now tati is suing
and she's a really small creator without
a crystal ball
for defamation which as you are touching
on suing someone for defamation
especially in california is pretty much
impossible to prove literally impossible
it's so and they get to like prove like
damages and like talk to you you know
what i mean everything
it's not even you have to prove that you
lost some money
no that's just that's the easy part you
have to prove that the person
knowingly lied about you and then still
went out of their way and specifically
damaged you yeah it's [ __ ] it is
[ __ ] that you can't like sue people
for that because people
like you said can say whatever they want
well and also as you noted she's a
public figure
right so she has less protection yeah
it's like you literally no i've learned
this
too like people can literally say
anything about you and it's like okay
well that's
yeah i mean yeah well crazy um well you
can sue people if they're lying about
you
it was like at a certain point it's so
expensive and dogs have a minimum to
start the lawsuit
twenty thousand hundreds of thousands i
mean just to even like start it like you
have to send them the cease and desist
they laugh at you whatever and then to
even start it it's like okay this and
then yeah and then like back and forth
hundreds of thousands
yeah i've been in los angeles to come to
fruition hundreds of thousands
easily you know i talked to a lawyer
because i was like keemstar just kept
lying like with this thing about
stealing money and all this and
that the video's still up and i was like
you know i'm just going to get some
uh counsel on this so i talked to this
lawyer
who's like uh became recommended highly
to me he
specialized in like high-profile
defamation cases
he says i think your case is actionable
but i have to tell you that
it's gonna this is gonna cost you at
least half a million dollars
yeah you know yeah i know and and then
well the good thing about keemstar is
that he does have money but in most
so he's like his first question was does
this guy even have money right because
if they have no money yeah i say he does
have money
but i was like i've been through an ugly
lawsuit i was like it's just not worth
it
but this girl katie joy without a
crystal ball
she doesn't strike me as someone who's
who is very wealthy and so
when you're suing someone like that for
defamation it's literally just to ruin
their life
yeah and but it's so pointless if you
don't own property i mean literally what
are they gonna do you know they don't
even garner
wages because i sued somebody once and
one and he had kind of money but
like i still haven't gotten paid from it
and like yes yeah and basically they
don't even like
his wages they don't even like what is
that called garner drummer like
he's getting income and he still hasn't
paid me he owes me 150
and he's kind of like a little high
profile-ish but he like somehow hid
money
for bank oh oh you know yeah
oh that's [ __ ] you know o.j simpson's
done that he owes them
he owes her family like millions of
dollars but he just [ __ ] up because in
florida they have like laws
that protect from garnishing wages and
stuff that must work out here because
this guy and then after 10 years or
something
it's like it just falls off or something
like it's great
like good luck getting the money you
know how hard it is so hard
it's so annoying but the one thing is
that if she so here's how the lawsuit
works if she doesn't
defend herself which is super expensive
and she
fails to respond then it's presumed to
kill and she loses
[ __ ] up it's gonna come back to tati
that greedy [ __ ] gonna get it
so she's suiting katie for defamation
for the fact that she
tarnished her reputation i mean she
doesn't even get that many views
they're seeking five million dollars in
damages
here's an old video katie describing
searching for info for tati's family
here okay here this oh yeah have you
seen this
you guys research i tell you remember
how i told you i was going to try to do
something where i exposed
tati westbrook and i was like
looking and i've been doing this for two
days straight now two days
thinking i would find something when i
started digging into her background and
i
have looked all over the place you guys
everywhere everywhere because
part of when a part of what i do is
i super chat what do you mean super chat
you can give me a super chat if you want
to give me a super chat but
by the way just give me five dollars
while i tell you this by the way the
fact she's suing her for definitely i
mean like yeah
there's probably like five people
watching this last thing
i like to look into people that sell
snake oil to see if they have stuff in
their background
that would make them less than
honorable um something that might
indicate that they are you know
there's something legal going on they
have a criminal background
they have um a criminal history
they owe money they have like
a reputation for doing all these things
and then when you go to her
her mother's page or her sister's pages
who are all still there
they're all like she's she doesn't exist
as a part of their family anymore
it's crazy i started playing around even
more
and digging through more and more
information going through
marriage records and through um
birth certificate oh my god i didn't
even find her birth certificate which is
weird
it's also creepy zero records of her
father like zero
so then i start going on and i'm like
getting into this conspiracy thinking
like her dad is dead or
oh my god why doesn't her dad have it i
mean this girl is crazy too
so then i start digging through
addresses and phone
email addresses and see all this doing
all these searches
and um going through businesses and
looking at all this different stuff to
try to like connect some dots
so i feel like there's a story here with
her dad and i'm not sure what it is
we're gonna have to keep looking there
oh my god then there's something with
her mom too and i'm just gonna have to
keep digging
i would say refer stalking more than
defamation that's that's not defamation
but it's super creepy
but she's a public figure people do this
to both of us yeah that's true
and by the way she's probably just on
like ancestry.com being like
looking at public white pages it's not
like she's in that [ __ ] cia hacking
yeah like the definition that's
something that's not defamation but it
sure is creepy but hey that's what
public figures deal with
and like that of all the drama channels
like why not spill tea or something big
buy that one that's so random
is that what it is yeah she's suing her
for five million dollars god
like oh that's just crazy damn so this
girl
deactivated her twitter and i guess
disappeared i guess that's what she
wanted from her but
damn like well she's [ __ ] but it's
like
but tati all i gotta say is tata tati
james charles has got to be loving it
though watching the demise of tati
he shouldn't love it too much because
it's gonna come around and the karma's
gonna get him too he needs to just chill
and that's my advice what tell me
right oh they're allied well that's what
tati said and i talked to james and
we're all good i mean
but were they like go after them or
whatever
but um yeah i think being humble is the
best way to go being cocky i first of
all i've
never been cocky i've always liked hated
myself and thought i was a piece of [ __ ]
but i'm saying in general people should
be humble
because and can i tell you that's
actually worked for me or just hate
yourself
yeah maybe humble or self-clothing no
but just stay humble
people who get cocky like the ray
william johnson's toby turns like all
these people probably nobody knows who
those are i'm just talking about them
but
like those are like people that get too
cocky and then [ __ ] comes around to them
like just stay humble
what i wish is that james charles just
gets some good dick
and i think he'll chill but he says he's
virgin i just i can't believe that he's
a virgin i don't believe it i can't
believe it i could believe it for sure
well but like he's so thirsty do you
think
and he's famous and he's rich he can't
get dick
this is going to sound so stupid but
like quick question if he has never had
sex i just thought about the sound like
how does he know he doesn't like
vagina i'm i don't think do you know
what i mean
i think i know what you think you mean
but i don't think that's what makes you
be gay
no i know but like here's my thing i
think he looks at me and he's attracted
to men
but i think i was like i thought i was
like i don't know maybe i am
but i thought i was bisexual for a long
time identify as bisexual and then i was
like with the woman and the first woman
i was was like oh i really don't like
this
but then now i'm with girls i'm like oh
i like it but am i bisexual i think
you're more fluid you know but i think
james is like really gay yeah but he's
never
tried but i guess well i'm sure you've
seen a vagina online i mean it's hard to
avoid especially follows you on twitter
i don't think he follows me i don't send
unsolicited [ __ ] you should send him to
him and see if he's like are you sure
you're gay here's my [ __ ]
oh that backfired on me a couple times
the guys have actually turned gay
or i don't think they turn gay i think
they're just like i'm getting that girl
i am now
i think i've turned people gay and i
know that's like not a thing and that's
not literacy you know i love my gays we
started out with that
but i do feel like there's been guys
that have been with me like i'm gonna
try it with a girl and they're like oh
definitely gay
you know what i mean like i've had gay
friends want to try it i'm like oh i'm
the one to try it with does that feel
bad or are you like uh whatever
does it do you really feel bad when that
happens kind of i kind of feel good that
they want to try it with me
but then when they're like definitely i
want to take it personally i think that
you probably just hang around with gay
dudes and they're like
if you see you're like safe and not
judging for sure
for sure i've been with some yeah really
really gay guys and
but i'm assuming a guy like charles
because i i really do think sexuality is
like a spectrum and i think
someone like james is probably without
knowing him personally probably like
pretty
but he's never tried yeah but like for
me when i look at when
when i look at men i don't want to [ __ ]
men you know what i mean no i don't
[ __ ] men it's just you know i don't
think there's really that much of a
mystery where you're like oh
it's vagina i think the worst part is
when they stick it in and it goes soft
the gay guys you're just like oh i'm so
sorry like i feel bad like i'm literally
dick repellent
i literally the boner killer you're like
oh you're the raid of [ __ ]
but they aren't gay in my defense they
weren't they did tell me they were gay
they wanted to try it
it's a bad feeling just uh limp dick in
you all of a sudden
it's like oh yeah
all right let's wrap it up yeah anything
else go [ __ ] vote
pause this go vote we need you now
trisha obviously thinks that tweeting a
billion spent the president should be on
twitter all day right
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter and climate change
if michael keaton swore i'm for it can
we get him on the podcast please if you
know michael keaton
yeah yeah yeah send this to michael
keane i love my boyfriend i've been very
grumpy too lately i'm so sorry
really you guys been fighting i've just
been very grumpy and he's so patient and
so nice i'm
so sorry i literally have you been have
you been losing patience with her at all
no he's literally like the most nice
literally he literally is he's an angel
it was his birthday and i was like
and he was just so nice he's couldn't be
nicer he's the nicest person in the
whole world so be nicer to him
i'm just some grumpy i have something
really wrong with me that i just need to
like snap
i don't know what's wrong with me like i
literally i'm just like okay well you
guys will work it out you'll figure it
out but he doesn't deserve my meanness
i'm not mean i'm just growing i know
what you mean i feel like that sometimes
with you
really where you're just kind of not in
a long time i used to be really or well
when we first met we've been together
for a long time you know yeah
so i guess there was a point in time
where i was super stressed like really
really stressed and i was super
irritable
but after that when i started taking
antidepressants like i'm like
it stopped i think i need to do that but
they just [ __ ] me up oh i need to find
a solution
because i do think i'm depressed i have
no reason to be like i'm actually really
happy and i think i'm like depressed
i don't i don't know if i'm really lucky
but like the lexapro for me is like
i've been on that it's all good for me
and that there's like
really no side effects it's just my
suicide attempts are on lexapro
see that full yeah then obviously don't
do that
no i know i'm so but there's i know
doctors say there's like all kinds of
different anti-presences
i've done like everything i'm really
scared for myself
well see a psychiatrist and work with
them yeah that's what i need to actually
you know what i mean like you gotta just
test and test and see what works
i'm just so scared to get on something
because i know how i am when i'm like
on bad meds like worse almost like now
i'm just kind of moody
well it's good that moses is with you
you can keep an eye if you're acting out
of character and
just keep your psychiatrist that on a
you keep them close
yeah if you can call or message if
something's off and moses
should have their contact too if we'd be
like yo the shit's off the rails
no but like i'm happy and i tell like
sometimes i'm so [ __ ] happy and i'm
like oh my god like i'm really happy
but then sometimes i get so moody and i
snap that's my thing i kind of snapped
like
what the [ __ ] like i get really like
like anger like no i know what you mean
and i apologize right away like the next
like i'm like god i'm so [ __ ] sorry
why did i do that i think you're just
i think you have you sounds like you
have mood swings so you need something
to stabilize you know
you know what a way to end that what the
[ __ ] do i know
but anyway you guys will figure it out
dr drew back when is dr drew coming back
i think you just need to talk to you're
like when do i get to have therapy again
just go see a therapist i know i had a
really bad headache after that episode i
like i had to get a jambo juice i'm like
we need a job but he's my head hurts my
head was like throbbing it was a good
episode though right
um yeah i think every time i cry i start
getting like a headache
yeah what happy election day yeah
happy election day guys let's [ __ ] go
democracy
don't drink dunkin donuts my heart is
racing
all right guys we'll see you next week
this has been frenemies the
non-halloween edition we didn't even
mention that but it's nice not to be in
drag for once
alright guys see you later